what do I recommend that you look at the
menu and act like you've been in a bar
before
[Music]
no I don't know what that drink is but
I'll google it in the back kela shot
there's like terrible not so terrible or
impress people with your money no I
can't recreate that drink you have that
one time at that one bar here's a twelve
dollar cocktail made with the cheapest
booze we have enjoy that's definitely a
picture of your sister take all the
money I can get oh you don't want to
give me your credit card because you
think I should trust you even though
we've never met I'm judging the [ __ ] out
of you for your drink for jagerbomb I
hope you and your friends die in a
hazing accident Long Island iced tea
sure thing garbage person oh you think
that I'm wearing this low-cut shirt to
get your phone number give me your money
we are not a team you creep me out
imagine how she feels I poured you the
wrong kind of wine but I'm pretty sure
you can't tell the difference make it
strong that should be stronger for you
it's the same drink but I put a tiny
drip of rum in the straw I don't need to
shake it this much but it looks cool
it's tips tips tips tips it's tips tips
I've had six shots this [ __ ] I've done
12 tips
I've been watering down your drinks
because you're turning into a drunk
[ __ ] this is basically just sprite
and fruit juice but you're too drunk to
realize it you were here first but she's
more attractive I'm gonna go with her oh
my god I totally don't know what you're
talking about what you're lonely and you
paying cash I'm pretending like we
didn't hook up that one time we all are
no pressure but last call was 25 minutes
ago and I can't wait for you guys to
leave you know we have food here you
have to keep sneaking out and you think
I'm not looking Oh what am i doing after
work not hanging out with you I'm just
doing this until my Etsy account takes
off I've given up on my dreams I can't
remember what you ordered because I'm
wasted